failed former president donald trump is
now under criminal investigation for
espionage yes violations of the
espionage act my how quickly political
fortunes can turn two weeks ago joe
biden's presidency was very stagnant
record low approval rating donald trump
seemingly coasting to a probable 2024
republican presidential nomination
seemingly unable to be touched and in a
two-week period on the joe biden side
blockbuster jobs report just
extraordinary inflation down
wages up passing the pact act passing
the inflation reduction act
uh and on the other hand
donald trump now subject to an fbi
search warrant executed at his home in
florida
with multiple multiple
different
criminal investigations taking place
let's take it step by step we will get
to possible prison time a little bit
later in the show but to start with the
fbi search warrant has leaked and it
shows that donald trump is under
investigation for potential obstruction
of justice and yes espionage act
violations and we will look at the
details of that trump criminality going
radioactive
a search warrant unsealed friday reveals
that the fbi
is investigating donald trump
for potential violation of the espionage
act and that agents removed classified
documents from the former president's
florida estate earlier this week
a receipt accompanying the search
warrant shows trump possessed documents
including a handwritten note documents
marked with t s sci which is the highest
one of the highest levels of government
classification and another item labeled
info regarding the president of france
the executive grant of clemency for
roger stone was in those items the
warrant shows federal law enforcement
was investigating trump for removal or
destruction of records
obstruction of justice and violating the
espionage act which can encompass crimes
beyond spying such as the refusal to
return national security documents upon
request conviction under the statutes
can result in imprisonment or fines now
one of the things that has also
developed over the weekend
is a seemingly
impossible to unwind
series of claims
about
whether or not the documents were even
at mar-a-lago and it's beyond our
ability to unpack it today and quite
frankly
it's not even the most interesting part
of the story but i should in order to be
thorough mention that endlessly
conflicting claims have been made first
it was there were no documents then it
was the fbi planted the documents then
it was the documents were there but they
were returned by june
so then they must have been planted or
maybe not and then it became yeah the
documents were there and it was
completely fine and legal for the
documents to be there it's a witch-hunt
going after trump for something which
isn't even a crime then it was well i
declassified the documents they were
there but i declassified them even
though there's no evidence that they
were declassified and then trump claimed
well i had a standing order that
anything i take home gets declassified
which is not how declassification works
it is an endless mishmash a gish gallop
a throwing
ketchup for lack of a better term at the
wall
to see what will stick and where we are
at the end is with the unsealed warrant
now the knowledge that part of this
investigation is into trump for possible
violations of the espionage act not
literal spying but a number of crimes
that fall under the general uh umbrella
espionage well so if you are for law and
order
and there is an investigation going on
into
an individual for the violation of
particular laws
what do you say
well if you rand paul you say cancel the
espionage act it's unbelievable let's
talk about that next your internet
provider websites you visit social media
companies they all follow you around
online and profit from selling your data
anyone can piece together this data
about you it's quite disturbing the
solution is make yourself anonymous with
private internet access our sponsor
private internet access has gone further
than any other vpn to demonstrate their
commitment to your privacy they don't
collect or store any data about user
activity they've proven this in court
multiple times their software is 100
open source so you can see that no data
is being logged everybody should be
using a vpn for your research on which
vpn is most trustworthy i think you'll
land where i did private internet access
it's great for streaming they have 24 7
customer support they have a 30-day
money-back guarantee if you don't love
it you can choose from ip addresses in
84 countries and all 50 u.s states and
my audience gets 82 off so you can stay
protected for just two dollars and 11
cents a month plus you'll get three
months free go to
privateinternetaccess.compacman
the link is down below